five four three two one zero
fireworks cool nuclear warfare is not an
nuking the moon doesn't that sound just
plain crazy
what would happen would we be able to
see the blast how would we be affected
by the fallout
when we even survived this is what if
and here's what would happen if we
detonated a nuclear bomb on the moon in
1957 the Soviet satellite Sputnik
successfully orbited earth putting
Russia ahead in the space race not to be
outdone the American government decided
to nuke the moon the u.s. believed that
a lunar explosion visible from Earth
would showcase American firepower and
improved morale at home how about it
would seeing something like this in the
sky give you peace of mind the most
powerful nuclear bomb created has a
yield of 50 megatons of TNT the
equivalent of 3,800 Hiroshima bombs
wondering how nuking the moon would
affect humanity the short answer is this
it wouldn't you're gonna need a bigger
bomb roughly 10 trillion megatons of TNT
bigger an explosion that size would
likely push the moon out of Earth's
orbit exposing us to meteors affecting
our tides while catastrophic ly
affecting our seasons but that's a
what-if for another time so while our
bomb might not be able to knock the moon
off its trajectory could our experiment
drastically affect its radiation levels
that would be a big problem among the
many reasons the u.s. canceled the 1958
plan to nuke the moon apart from the
worldwide disapproval was the idea that
the nuclear fallout would ruin the
military's plans to colonize the moon by
1967 but our moon isn't like earth it's
not protected by an ozone layer meaning
it's directly exposed to cosmic rays and
solar flares this results in high levels
of space radiation on the moon's surface
and so much of it the radioactive
fallout from a single nuclear explosion
would hardly make a difference
interestingly NASA is still looking for
a way around the moon's radiation
problem since it helps to build and
staff a lunar base there in the near
future if we detonated a nuke on the
moon the most damage we might do
physically is add another crater to its
surface which is ironic since the moon
gets its craters from blocking
meteorites heading for Earth so maybe we
should stop trying to attack it and be
grateful for its defenses and the
seasons and the tides
[Music]
you